then they say oh Dwayne and Dakota the
cows have no legs
[Music]
I always tell the story of my South
American friends coming to South Dakota
and seeing all the balers we use here
because it's a very predominant thing to
do is to bail hay up and move it into
the feedlot for the winter time and they
they would see that and they say oh
Dwayne and Dakota the cows have no legs
meaning that the cows should be able to
walk out and get her own food and I
think that's exactly right it just saves
us a lot of money and it keeps us from
hauling nutrients back and forth how
many pounds of nutrients go to that
feedlot well they don't really get back
the nitrogen for sure doesn't get back
and if we take the manure in the form of
getting a phosphorus and potassium back
yeah that kind of works but it again is
another fossil fuel thing so we're
trying to take the fossil fuel guy out
of it